[Music]
hey what's up beautiful people
how are you guys doing today today we're
gonna be talking about external versus
internal validation magnet of corner oh
I kind of like that I feel like you were
sitting on that way too fast it was
Tuesday topic is horny what very horny
what is external validation and what is
internal versus external validation not
horny internal validation horny so what
is the difference external is when
people tennis is outside of you and
internals when a penis is in well I
don't want penis that one I'm never
gonna have the internal validation means
he likes you external means he doesn't
like you he isn't one of them I be in
you is external like hey you're pretty
and then internal is like I'm pretty in
my opinion internal validation is
internal validation is when you know
yourself you know yourself fully and
that no matter what bullets are coming
in and things they're people saying to
you that's not true
like if somebody says god you're so
stupid if you know you're not stupid
then you're like [ __ ] you but if you
still are not sure about yourself if you
don't know your strengths your
weaknesses when somebody says oh you're
so stupid you'll be like oh I'm sorry
like those are the people that don't
have any like internal confidence
because when you have that and you know
who you are you're almost unshakable but
in that fulfills you every day every
morning when you wake up because that
does not change you're very ye go
maniacs and narcissists win yeah true
yeah but they're usually not right then
it's not really fueled by something
healthy but yeah but their internal
validation is extremely very people are
in the middle like you I think it's also
like you can't be on the polar spectrum
of either/or because when you're two
internal validation you become two I
mean to the point where you don't listen
to anybody
yes I mean I believe that to a point
like I I say that just because like I I
read something one time big Oprah fan
and over
says knowing who you are because my I
had a big issue with external validation
for the longest time and she said you
have to know yourself I spent two years
discovering my strengths and weaknesses
a weakness is a part of who you are and
I think maybe narcissus missed that part
because they have no damn no weaknesses
that's true that's the unhealthy side of
it yeah I'm a big Harvey Weinstein fan
so it's kind of like you like their
friends you know their buds so yeah like
like no matter what they say about
Harvey I know harvest Oprah loved him so
like an example would be someone that's
a influencer right and if your external
validator then you're constantly
checking how many likes and comments and
love and what people so your sense of
skill self all that stuff is determined
by yeah whatever people say but if
you're internally validating yourself
you just do the dude you just do the
[ __ ] work you don't care how many
whatever yeah yeah you you let your okay
the the best way I could think of it is
because like the way that I used to
think was oh my god I did this look at
this look at this accomplish that
accomplishment I made and I needed
people to pat me on the back for the
accomplishment but I started to rewire
my brain to be like look at all the work
I put in up until receiving that
accomplishment because the work is
really me and the fact that I was able
to do that is what is like not you can't
really take that from me
but the accomplishment itself is
fleeting and that's very external a
couple years ago I was accused of hating
women because I did a video where I went
to a women's rights March and I held
those sandwich-making competition oh my
god that was you yeah and they were they
do too fast sandwich by the way and and
and so but the whole to me the joke of
that was that they were [ __ ] cool
like they weren't like I'm gonna burn my
brow and all this [ __ ] like they were
just [ __ ] cool and they were laughing
and smiling and going with the bit
didn't take themselves too seriously and
that's that's what was fun about that
and so I got so much hate for that but I
knew why I did it
right so my internal validation was like
I know exactly why I did this [ __ ] like
this makes these chicks look awesome
like if anything the joke is on me
because I'm doing a bunch of bits yeah
you're making yourself look the [ __ ]
like I do massa yeah these guys these
girls are being awesome so
so yeah and that kind of shows like a
bunch of people who think that all these
wins rates people are so [ __ ] rigid
like they're not there they're actually
humans they're pretty cool too one girl
actually make you an excellent sandwich
she may be an incredible sandwich very
fast by the way very quick so yeah I was
timing them so she better but yeah or
like external validation is like wow I
really like this person I want to get
them well I only want to date them to
validate like sometimes people will try
to date people above their tier like
those eight people that they think is
like out of their reach and then when
they lock that person in they're like
yeah I'm worthy and like then it just
goes away and then they don't value that
person anymore and now you have this
person that was really just an
accomplishment for you and [ __ ] stuff
yeah that was a lot it really does we um
so on my 90 days to freedom course I
have a segment on like what yeah I have
a segment what if I'm at 90 days to
freedom yeah I yeah I have it on my
Instagram so if you go on my Instagram
it's a link it's a it's the link it's
the color yeah yup I like it I'll give
it to you all but you guys could all
have it but here's the thing okay so
there's this one segment that we have
called achievement versus fulfillment so
a lot of people they try to find
validation through achievement but
you're just it's an endless chase
because you don't ever feel the best if
you don't have the number one right but
in reality what should happen is through
the journey you should have fulfilment
but a lot of people don't make that
agreement with themselves if they if
they've set up a goal cuz I also believe
that you need goals to feel like you're
having progression in life but if you
don't hit if you don't hit the goals
with the with an agreement of when I hit
this goal the fulfillment is this yes I
celebrate this way what else right mark
Manson talks about this in one of his
books where he's like humans think that
like once I get here then I'll be happy
right though people don't realize is you
actually achieve happiness through
solving problems therefore if you don't
have any problem exactly we're not happy
because you get you get that happiness
from solving problem it's like when you
watch a movie and there's no
conflict in the movie you're bored oh my
god wait what was the revelation this
day and you feel like okay it's sure
like a cause like I was making was say
that oh yeah you know if you don't have
any problems like you're not gonna like
you don't expel like why am i tripping
over my words cause you had it at Eureka
I know um your body is still being you
you don't gain that satisfaction right
but then when you do have problem you
overcome it then you know you feel a lot
better I'm like that's right I felt like
I had a lot of issues I okay man now I
feel like a better person that's why
that's why people reminisce about the
times that they struggled a lot a lot of
times right and especially stories Oprah
does that where it's like you know I
look fondly upon my tragedy because it
helped me make make me who I am yeah I
think he has to come in like waves
though right cuz when you're too long
into down that's when depression hits
because it feels like nothing ever yeah
yeah can go back up but that's why
humans need challenge and progress and a
little bit of winds to bring them back
up the swing and it's like you win hard
again and then you're gonna go down
because you can't avoid deaths in the
family you can't avoid naturally human
things that kind of is gonna [ __ ] with
the emotions and that's what Harvey
wants she's going through right now you
know he's getting the maximum are you
gonna make a comeback bro like you're
he's are mad dude
he's getting so much conflict that he's
just gonna you know he's just gonna fly
out of this wood wings I think it's
interesting you say that like if you
think of your life is just kind of like
almost like what is that heartbeat thing
like you know want to go the easy easy
right here yeah like the only way that
you get wins is if you take risks or
work really hard on something and if
you're just going through day by day
you're never doing either/or but life
will inevitably always throw you down
errs so if you're not trying your life
is just going like you know but you need
to have those ups to really appreciate
the downs but you need to work hard to
have those ups be an active echo echo
cardiogram yes exactly and it needs to
go boop boop boop boop and when you're
doing bad that's gonna go boo
I feel you I feel you you curve down
this whole video which is boobs let's do
it
oops oh no are you okay we both just
passed away on camera this video goes
passes away on camera both ends on
camera wait addresses back here I feel
like that when we're in our teens they
were very fragile right and like we
always want external validation just
because you know we don't know who we
are you haven't gone through cycles yeah
there hasn't been a self that's
developed so then like at what point for
you guys did you guys finally receive
your own internal validation oh god I
still am working on that yeah
well not that I look for external but I
live right internal tiny victories yeah
tiny victories no because that's how I
do everything how to celebrate tiny
victories too because I would often just
forget anything that I did don't always
felt like I didn't do anything like I
hadn't achieved anything and so I could
so recently I learned how to like
actually look and recognize when I did
things so that I could be like oh yeah I
am making progress because before I just
felt like an endless sea of never
winning I can I come from the not good
enough cash yes and I think that's just
our upbringing like if you're if because
I was told by my dad perfection is the
epitome everything has to be perfect so
if you yeah so it's like if your
half-assing well I think he was trying
to avoid half-assing behavior out of me
but the way he drilled it was you should
never be proud of half-assed work yes be
perfect all the time
do it right from the beginning because
their life shouldn't be with mistakes
right so I had that drained in me let me
drilled a me and he's like so every time
I approach something also there's
there's just guilt built on it because
we're not gonna be a hundred percent
we're gonna have fast stuff to but you
just keep doing it and doing it and it
nothing feels rewarding even if you
actually get a win because you're always
looking up because if this is if a win
is the expectation yeah then you just
did bare minimum
I win exactly and if you didn't win then
what the [ __ ] is your problem you're
never gonna be good enough so there's
never alike yeah because it's always
like well that was expected of me yes oh
yeah I felt like I had my internal
validation happened sometime towards the
end of college for me because like I
think all my life I felt like I never
really give a [ __ ] about myself
um but one pie I was like well why don't
I care about myself like who else is
gonna care about me me right and so I
just remember okay well [ __ ] yeah let's
let's hit the gym because I know you
want a rockin body let's uh let's go do
this Julia yeah let's go do that
together you know and it was just made
friends with yourself I need friends
with myself and it's just like yeah and
I just didn't know that it was something
that I needed personally and that it was
something of an option for me because I
always felt like being with the way that
my I don't know I I feel like with how
my mom treated with other people and
like how she interacted with them she
always treated herself as like always
beneath them all the time so like if
they gave her a gift she has to give
like a gift that's bigger or like
something of a similar value or she'll
be like oh no no like no I don't need it
I don't need it you take it back right
so to me it's just like oh I'm not
worthy of any of this [ __ ] so like you
guys take everything back you know so I
think for me in college I was like well
[ __ ] if I'm going like well what about
me you gotta go fill your cup in order
to get so hard though to tell somebody
who's like in a tailspin like if they're
going through something we're like
they're they feel like they're
completely [ __ ] right now like I got a
friend who's going through something
like in the media cycle it's like huge
and and he's overweight and he won't hit
the gym and I'm like Harv you gotta
[ __ ] just go to the gym at least
[Music]